We survived the blizzard coffee on a
Tuesday and blog,
49.
Life often perfectly manageable is
sometimes subject to intense and
revealing human moments.
Moments when the inscrutable veil that
is the exterior of ourselves suddenly
becomes transparent so that anyone in
the vicinity who can see us can also see
through us.
You know what I mean?
If you've ever been embarrassed or seen
someone embarrassed,
you know what I mean?
The machinations behind the eyes
normally,
so swift and indecipherable fall away
and you are left with the person so
utterly and pathetically readable.
We try our best to avoid moments like
this.
It's in our interest to be a mystery.
Most of the time in social
relationships,
people value unpredictability,
so we're unpredictable and there is no
nakedness more naked than the experience
of being figured out,
but here at nerdwriter industries,
we love this kind of moment because it
tells us something about people,
about naked people,
and we love people at their most naked.
No way that that came out wrong or did
it.
I live in New York City and I ride the
subway everyday.
The subway,
like a cafe is a place where people are
alone together.
Most people read books or listen to
music or just stare off into the middle
distance.
The subway is not a destination.
It's a place between destinations and we
have no intention of making it a
destination,
so we all agree not to speak to one
another.
Now,
one thing about the New York subway is
that it does have panhandlers homeless
people,
people down on their luck asking for
money and it's a pretty frequent
occurrence exacerbated I'd imagined by
the state of the economy.
These people,
despite their misfortunes,
wield and incredible power,
when they come onto the train and give
their speech,
always practiced,
always forceful.
They create one of these intense and
revealing human moments,
and a subway car of 50 opaque souls
becomes as transparent as clean water as
the downtrodden person,
either with musical instruments,
a sad face child or an associate.
A dog comes down the subway car in hand.
They force each and every writer to
confront their desperation.
A couple give a few coins or a dollar.
Some look up and shake their heads.
Most people just stare aggressively into
their books or at their feet ignoring
and refusing the shameless person's
existence.
People on the subway don't want this.
That's obvious.
A beggar violates the agreed rules of
the situation not to interact with.
Fact is that this person who may need
food or money to house their children or
money to pay for power has presented the
train car with an explicit moral
problem.
Should you give them money or not try as
we might.
There is no way once posed not to answer
this question.
I guess that the writers intuitive
dislike of being forced to do something
in a place where they expect to do
nothing is what influences most of them
not to give and make no mistake.
Most people don't.
This echoes the theme of my last Vlog.
We use our reason to justify our
feelings.
If you're offended by this person to
start,
then here are some reasons not to.
Maybe they won't use the money for food,
but instead for drugs,
maybe.
Maybe I'm making the problem worse.
This is my money.
I earned it.
I worked hard for it.
They have no right to that.
I don't have enough money myself to be
giving it away to others.
You know,
I only have a $5 bill in my wallet.
If I had a dollar bill or some coins,
you know I do it,
but you know five's too much.
You know what?
This will only perpetuate their
homelessness.
I know about these things.
They need to get a job.
I can't give everyday how much,
how much they want for me.
I'm not going to solve their problems is
useless to give it all.
If your inclination on the other hand is
to give,
then you have to ask,
should you give every time and how much
and to whom and knowing that beggars are
going to be on the subway.
Should you be sure to have money with
you always.
When you leave the house,
should you beat yourself up?
When you forget,
is it enough to deal with poverty?
Only when it crosses your path,
should you be allowed to feel good about
yourself?
If you give only once and it's only a
die,
there are no easy answers to these
questions,
nor is there an easy answer to the first
question.
The one in the moment when they hold out
their hand,
all I can say is trying not to make the
perfect the enemy of the good.
What I do know is that the no stops this
line of questioning in its tracks.
While the yes opens up that vast moral
web in which we are forced to consider
the needs and desires of others forced
to confront and workout are messy
responsibility in relation to everyone
else.
Still the fact is,
given the truth that almost everyone
doesn't give that there are a good
number of people like me that decided
that they should but don't.
I think this tension,
insights of valuable pain in our hearts,
but I have to wonder,
is it valuable enough?
Great.